[Music]
it's a special day
have no fear then Julian podcast is live
right now streaming live to devices and
things that's alive it's not alive
genuinely though what people who asked
us to go back to doing this live but I
don't think it would be the same yeah I
mean I'm not opposed to it but I also
like we would have to have a monitor
because we do it on Twitch right so they
would be just be like in front of the
camera right I mean you record live from
the side side angle
no like logistically is easy right like
you said yeah cuz we can set the main
camera up has like a source for OBS and
we just stream through rubble yes but I
just think like the [ __ ] like the
podcasts itself like when I listen to
podcasts I'm in a different mood than
what I'm listening to twitch streams cuz
I'm in the mood for both sometimes
sometimes I want to just like literally
like open up a Twitter stream like lock
my phone let the audio play and just
kind of hearing like dumb live stuff but
then other times I want to hear like a
discussion that that's not alive alright
that happened that I know there's like
an endpoint yeah I don't know why
well I found myself like sometimes I'll
watch the h3 podcast live stream and I
find that I listen to it like actively
listen to it far less than if I watch a
recorded episode agreed agreed
yeah I think there's a difference
between active listening when your life
and when it's recorded for some reason I
don't know why I don't I don't know why
I don't know what it's a special day
though because this podcast is coming on
Monday for us right now it's Sunday you
just went out to dinner for Julian's
birthday and tomorrow's your birthday
April 17th
happy birthday Julian thank you
thank you these are good we smashed
headphones we did smash headphones yeah
I don't know I guess how do you feel we
feel normal you turn 26
yeah you're the same age now that you I
was when I met you that's interesting to
think about isn't it it is because I
feel like if I were to have met you
right now I would have understood a lot
better I don't know just like where you
were in life and like I don't know it's
weird cuz I don't like feel like a
different person but I feel like I'm
living it different you know my guy in a
different life right now mm-hmm
cuz when I was 20 like just the way I
thought and the way I did things I'm the
same person right but I just it's like a
whole different life I don't know yeah
but no I mean ya know are you excited
yeah didn't you do I thought um when we
did the birthday podcast last year when
I was about when I was about 25 mm-hmm
didn't you say or didn't someone say
that like 25 is the worst like the worst
year yeah I forgot who said it I have to
go back and check in that podcast but it
was someone either in the comments or
someone I had talked to personally that
was Japanese and said that in Japan it's
like 25 was considered the worst year
tell me if I'm making that up
no I don't remember the root of that but
and I also had said that 25 was a
terrible year for me as well and I feel
like I know a lot of people that 25 was
a terrible year mm-hmm how was 25 for
you I it was a lot it was you know I
mean like it was I'm not gonna it's hard
to just give it a one-word answer like
it wasn't a good year wasn't a bad year
mm-hmm but it wasn't like a cursed year
like some people think it is no I mean I
don't I don't necessarily think like
there are certain curses that I would
buy more into than something just so
like cut and dry as like 25 yeah that's
so weird
I definitely feel like it was a testing
year it was like a trying year for me
like a transitional age yeah and like
certain things happened in my life that
I had to deal with for the first time as
a 25 year old hmm you know like as I'm
leaving 25 like I look back on some of
the things and like I don't know I just
think I encountered certain things that
I just hadn't before mm-hmm you know I
think death is one of them mm-hmm I was
really unfamiliar with death or losing
anyone close to me and I think that
happens to everyone at some point I
don't think there's anything special
about mid-20s no I think it happens just
kind of because of circumstance
obviously but I would say that's one of
the big things also learning that you
know I think learning that trying to
think of how to put this like things
that you had previously formed opinions
about may not be as built up in real
life as they are in your head mm-hmm you
know because I feel like there were a
few things that I went through as a 25
year old that I had entered the
experience with that preconceived kind
of formulated thought about it like I
know I know what this is I'm either
excited about it or I'm not or I hold
this to a certain regard and then I do
it and it's not bad at all it's more of
just like understanding that life and
like the circumstances of how random
life is applies to everything no matter
how much of an opinion or you know
conclusion you might have formed prior
yeah all right well I do feel like
mid-20s is such an age like you figure
it out in different circumstances as a
younger person but like mid-20s it's
really you're you're in that period of
like everyone fully expects you to be an
adult and you are still sort of let
still letting go of like you're your
young person habits and like trying to
be an adult but also feeling like you're
failing at being an adult and like not
wanting to be an adult but wanting to be
an adult
and it's just a weird weird age yeah I
think that's a good way to put it like
there are a lot of moments when you're
like I'm young like I'm in my mid-20s
yeah you're like I'm not supposed to
have it figured out but then there are
other moments you're like [ __ ] like
mid-20 is actually to have some figured
out there's there's like these moments
and in any parts of your ear 20s where
just like you said it things just don't
work or happen the way that you thought
that they would and I think it's I think
that whole decade I'm only you know two
years out of it but like that whole
decade is really you learning how to
take your expectations of life versus
your actuality of life and then making
things work for you you know because
every kid has these ideas of what their
life's gonna look like at a certain age
as a teenager what you think and then
yeah you know you have a bunch of
setbacks or you get blown off course or
you know things out of your control
happen and it's all about figuring out
how to pick yourself back up and make
your reality the best you can you know
yeah I'd stay sane during it and have a
positive attitude because it gets real
easy in there to just get really really
discouraged I feel like yeah and I think
being 25 and turning it to 26 is
characterized like nicely by how I just
like didn't care about my worth this
year and it's true I'd like it wasn't it
wasn't a joke and I wasn't trying to
like whatever it was just like I
genuinely the topic of my birthday was
just like oh I don't know it's not it
doesn't excite me and not in like a
depressing like oh I'm getting old and
grumpy found away it's just like you
know when you're young and your birthday
is this magical time and like you look
forward to it and you have these high
expectations but I think it goes back to
the expectations thing about just like
life that like you learn that
expectations you know that's what's
causing the route yeah some of your
unhappiness yeah expectations can be bad
you're holding yourself to this thing
you had in your mind that doesn't even
make any sense
now that you're here you know
so let go of them and then just try and
enjoy yourself yeah it was like Julian
what do you want to do for your birthday
and you were like I don't know maybe go
out to dinner you know something really
like you're twisting my arm over here I
don't think we can make that happen but
even like okay so several years ago we
had a big party at the house like rhpc
was here like our friends you know and
you have these years where you'd be
really disappointed if you didn't see
your friends for your birthday you know
what I mean and then last year it was
like all right and even it's making more
adult version of that like it was a big
year though I feel like it's like one of
those landmarks or birthdays where you'd
like to celebrate it a little more than
others and so we we have 23 was the keg
party 24 you took me to Joshua Tree oh
that's right so we skipped a year of
parties and then 25 last year yeah we
went to a bar yeah with a bunch of
friends but still not like tons of
friends it was a mod mod a group like
not a lot of people but people that do
jujitsu had a lot of like people
grabbing me by my sweatshirt it's your
mo different like tribe secret society
in grab each other by the sweatshirt in
the neck here and then you say oh it's a
toy okay for a secret society wait
pretty that's it that's a pretty big
giveaway for it is a handshake it's not
very much of a secret okay what the hell
was that can you explain this can you do
it to me at the same time like this no
if anything it would be something along
like a tough quick hey that could be a
that's very easy to turn a jujitsu club
into a secret society now that you think
about it because you're already meeting
regularly right right you already have
that carved out where people don't raise
an eyebrow you all wear the same thing
yeah we're already in uniform we're in
our well that's only if it's gay jujitsu
Oh
that's a noogie is a whole different
cult that's naked you do that's not a
thing to ask you you wanna go noogie
like just butt naked you wanna get in no
no I did think it was really interesting
though because ever since I've known you
since you were you know it's six years
now that I've known you since you were
six what you said since you were six
know you've always hung out with people
that are older than you it's because
you're a mature person and you see value
in people that handle themselves in a
way that you admire you know like I
don't see you hanging out with people
that don't like push you in some sort of
way and as I've watched you you know
grow into the person that you are it's
like you found this jujitsu gym and I'm
like cool yeah I can't wait to meet your
friends cuz it had been like a year or
two that you'd been going there yeah
girl they want you to meet my friend
Jason or like coach and stuff and I meet
all these people but like I hear about
them but then I meet them and I realize
that they're all like mid-40s I love
kids they're like some cops like people
that need to turn cops and you come home
and you'll talk about them you know like
they're people that you just relate to
but on paper it's always so funny to me
that I'm like all right here's Julianne
like even the first time I met you like
yeah here's one of my best friends
leaves mark and he's a 40 year old and
it's funny because I think that you're
just like yeah you identify and relate
to people that will push you and inspire
you and like that's that's what you like
in people and that's what draws people
to you and you to people and that's like
I've watched a lot of people get excited
about your energy and helping you you
don't mean because if you have knowledge
right or something where you could help
someone no one likes a lazy student that
is just sort of like half listening to
you and when someone takes like a
genuine interest in something that
you're doing and it's really excited and
really wants to do it like you are that
person in so many different things that
I've watched you try
or do or succeed in like you know when
you were doing Olympic weightlifting and
you know you quickly just excel in
whatever you put your mind to because
you're you're in Aries and it's not the
only reason but you know I mean you're
just an excited student of whatever
you're focusing your energy into and
you'd like attract people that have
something to teach you I feel like
because of that like it's so exciting to
teach someone that is so thirsty and so
appreciative you know and you are that I
mean that honestly feels like a really
nice compliment so thank you I
appreciate that
you said that about me I mean I I really
do feel like like as a person who you
know in college and past college like
didn't like what I wasn't really in a
large group of friends ever right like
even in high school I had like a handful
of friends and as I like transitioned it
sort of being a young adult in college
and in the workplace like I got really
lucky like I met some really really
great people who yeah we're a lot older
than me but they also saw that I was
willing to learn bread is a great
example bread is a big reason why you
know this whole concept is a big reason
why I'm very close friends with Brett
and now you are to is because like you
know I've gotten lucky to meet people
like Brett like Mark who have recognized
that I'm just willing to learn that's
really kind of all it started with and
then the time of day that I'm given by
people who are much wiser and older
transitions into friendship and then all
of a sudden all my friends are 10 year
10 20 years older than me and that's
great because you know I feel like
that's a big reason why I vibe with you
and why I was able to kind of catch up
in a certain sense even though I'm
younger than you I feel like like older
is where I want to be with people and
yeah and like the jujitsu thing is so
funny cuz like my friend Jason he's 35
here and were like we're boys like I
like we have conversations and like we
talk about life and everything it just
it doesn't really register that that
even matters because if you're willing
to listen to someone
if you're willing to talk to someone
relate to someone and learn from them
like yeah yeah I think you have more to
gain than someone your exact age okay so
when you talk to your your wise
grandparents and you're listening the
stories and if you want to listen you're
gonna gain some wisdom but it's like
that on a smaller scale well I mean I
feel like a lot of people obviously hang
out with people that are older and have
conversations with people that are older
I've just never met anyone who's like
majority of friends are all at least
five years older than at least five yeah
but that's really
sq up you skew but I like even to this
day like when I watched you with the
twitch stream you you then taught me but
originally you had completely taught
yourself the entire sort of ropes to the
streaming world and I continued to watch
you reach out to people that you admire
that you know are you good at what they
do professional and you just have this
way of really genuinely approaching
people and acknowledging that they are a
master at something and if they'd ever
be willing to teach you something like I
want your friendship with Matt Joe's who
does you know hi pearl axes and time
lapses and how old is not Joe's yeah
Joe's I think he is now he's 28
yeah Matt Joe's is wonderful I adore him
but like it's probably not maybe it is
now maybe not when you reached out to
him because you really you found him on
reddit right um yeah I found him already
I never really reached out I I sort of
just became like a silent viewer yeah so
I subscribe his channel
I like binge watches his whole [ __ ]
channel and I would soundly watch for
like a year and then I finally like left
to comment right and he like found me
and then we connected but yeah like I I
just I think that when you have a
particular skill yeah and someone is
like man that is so [ __ ] cool
would you ever mind you know teaching me
some stuff yeah it's incredibly
flattering and you're like yeah dude I'd
love to yeah it would be my pleasure
yeah and I also feel like when you like
if you treat that opportunity when you
reach out to someone as like don't do
that to everyone
it's special when you do that mhm
it comes from a more genuine place of
interest and and you know intrigue like
I feel like that what you know what that
feels like when someone reaches out to
you you're like hey general like you
know I you're like the best of the best
at this one thing and I just want you to
know that I've really admired that you
do it so well and if you'd ever be
willing to maybe give me some tips I'd
appreciate I get so sometimes when you
do I don't mean from a rhythm I mean the
person you've had it in the Queen's with
or a friend or something I think for for
friends or people that I know the
majority of the the conversations sort
of end up on education hmm well you're
you're a master at education dojo daddy
master and education yeah but I mean I'm
just that shit's crazy to me and you
glaze over that pretty easily every
times I'm gonna ask but you got your
masters in mm-hmm
- one year one year yeah that's nuts
it's called the fast-track program it
was absolutely insane so like can you
break down because I don't know the like
for an undergrad I know the credits and
stuff and how that all works out what it
look like for a master's degree like
what's the traditional length of time
that you would spend two years two years
and you do it in half the time
mm-hmm and and like compare that to
undergrad like how is it different how
is it the same just structurally like
structurally you still have classes yes
so go to classes you still write papers
and I'm just speaking for my friend
exactly yeah I don't know I can't speak
to like if you would like to go to
medical school I mean I've had friends
do both and you basically just say
goodbye to them for about three to five
years in law school yeah we got law
school to it but for me it was the the
easy transition for my undergraduate was
that you still go to classes and have a
schedule like he usually would so on my
first day I'm pumped right like I'm
excited you know I'm squishing in
basically two years into one year and so
I have a fair amount of classes but
still I'm like alright there's some time
in here what I'm gonna be able to maybe
have a part-time job or you know keep my
part-time Bob my part-time jobs are at
night for the most part because I was
go-go dancing bartending that kind of
thing so I wasn't super concerned about
that but you know maybe I could pick up
a shift at the tanning salon or
something you know what I mean three is
a day on the eastern day so I get my
schedule and they're all classes are no
longer like Monday Wednesday Friday 9:30
to 10:30 you know you have like some
classes that are shorter and some that
are longer often you have them yeah all
your classes are like three hours yeah
and how many times a week I don't for
you is probably different the average
message I don't remember but it's all my
classes were like three hours late
lecture hall yeah not lecture halls just
they were three hours like normal
classes were three hours yeah I mean
there's not a lot of people that's
that's another big day that's also
interesting but I mean Suffolk for me my
undergraduate was small so I was used to
small classes but I'm saying like some
of them like well I would have to take a
bus to go to the medical school to do a
fair amount of my classes because it is
a psychology degree so studying in
Boston University Medical School for
some of them and you're in there sort of
with people that might go on to get it
now let me see or like it certified
mental health counselor or they might go
on to get a PhD and become a
psychologist or psychiatrist or whatever
but um the other portion of my classes
were mixed in between the the school of
Sciences and then sort of where the
sports and that sort of thing was and
like within our program like the people
in my program there's only you know I
think 13 people sure
so when we and even that was broken into
subgroups of my advisor and the other
advisor who was her husband this is
magical so we would have you know a
three hour long class of the six of us
sitting and talking about our
internships so that was when I first get
my schedule I'm like okay this seems
totally doable
there are long classes but like the ski
not completely out of control and then
your first you know sitting down with
your advisor is like alright today we're
placing you in your internships mm-hmm
and that's gonna take up every hour for
the class and then that's what it hit me
like oh that's [ __ ] nuts yeah cuz like
an underground it's like you know
depending on your major it's like okay
you know here here's what the
internships traditionally you know
involve and here are some different
companies and do like if you want credit
for that yeah but it's not like you're
hustling at your [ __ ] internships
every day like you are yeah cuz that's
insane well and like you know we had a
couple of internships you know like in
the mornings on certain days but like a
lot of days I was going over to the
middle school high school that I was
working at in the same yeah and teaching
in Jamaica Plain and teaching kids
physical responsibilities their their
social responsibilities activity so we
worked with the baseball and softball
teams that would be very early in the
morning and then classes all day and
then I would have an internship at night
where I worked with bu student-athletes
where you talk to them like a
performance hands enhancement like that
kind of thing the the idea behind having
all these different internships is
figuring out what you're good at because
there's a difference between what you're
good at and what you like you know what
I mean so that's it honestly it makes so
much more sense than the traditional
like get an internship and then be done
with it because like if you don't like
it then what the [ __ ] are you wasting
your time on right you're not seeing if
there's another option out there while
you're trying that yeah
so you're it's very different than
undergraduate and that maybe you might
get an internship as an upperclassman
yeah you know doing something sort of
related to something that you're doing
or you know it's an unpaid intern
whatever yeah parts of our program are
structured to sit down and talk about
your internships and how they're going
and how you can do better and how you
can actually practice what you're doing
you know just like a regular checkup of
where you're at with all this [ __ ]
you're doing yeah it was like it was
high key awesome so yeah it was it was
crazy and then I worked at night so it
was like [ __ ] feed yourself to feed
my yeah
yes to feed myself put that hustle is
crazy yes so crazy it was wild but
anyways I don't that was a weird tangent
but basically I feel like most people
that ask me questions are along the
lines of higher education I don't really
have a lot of people asking me unless
they're like close friends or people
that you know genuinely ask me questions
I think even though I have a very um I
would say independent view like I do a
lot of things differently than other
people on the Internet
I would say but for the most part it's
people asking me about education yeah
yeah because there's a lot of people
that don't they don't know anybody
that's gone to graduate school let alone
college for some people were the first
person I had old to have someone's
advice yeah I think pretty for you the
first person I've met that I'm actually
known about what like you know that you
went to graduate school and then my
sister did after yeah a few years later
but no it's super [ __ ] interesting
because and that's why I like ask you
like logistically like what does it look
like oh it's just every hour of every
day you know no joke every hour of every
day like it's like basically like
college but if you replace the social
and fun part of college with more
college yeah president ears in
undergraduate for me like a lot of
people you know you you're the first
thing that my softball coach said to me
was you're gonna have more free time
than you've ever had in your life
and I sort of half believed her and then
when I got my class schedule I was like
you know you're right because what the
[ __ ] do you do with this like you you
can schedule your classes from 9:00 to
12:00 or 9:00 to 1:00 and one day knock
them all out and then you have like all
these hours in the afternoon so a lot of
people get part-time jobs or for me that
was never a thing because you
have to schedule all your your classes
between 8 a.m. and 12:00 or 1:00
Froggers hop obligations because then
practice was every day in the afternoon
so I mean that was a lot too but I mean
going from that sort of structure and
undergraduate and then all of your
obviously your weekends are all practice
all of your Spring Break is all travel
if your holidays are basically either
travel or training like you go home but
you also have this book of weight
training that you take to execute you
come back
you can't come but that I think that's
what made that transition easier for me
is that my my days had already been
packed from sometimes 5 a.m. to you know
8 9 10 p.m. and then you get home and
you have to feed yourself and do all
your homework damn dude I that's crazy I
did an internship you know about this I
did an internship for a whole summer
like this basically a spring in the
summer yeah and never went in time to
get them assignments so I waited like a
half a year and I went back and they had
gone out of business so they were
nowhere so it was the internship that
wasn't didn't exist it didn't I help you
get a college credit do you know you
didn't you did because I was in that
pickle where I had [ __ ] up by doing
internship but then forgetting to get
the signatures in time because I was
like I'll get him when I get him yeah
but that wasn't even your fault no good
company like shut down shut down all
their emails stopped working I couldn't
find any contact it was I be in sports
there's actually a few clips on you got
me doing stuff for them that's not your
fault
if you still should have gotten that
credit you did the full internship yeah
so I'm like sitting there putting my
credit together and
and like things aren't adding up I'm
like oh I need my [ __ ] internship
credits [ __ ] it so I'm like okay I reach
out to them like hey can you guys just
please sign this and send it back
nothing no response again nothing I'm
like you know what I'm just gonna like
Google really quick audience person I
spell it right
obvious words that com domain nothing
what I was there for a summer I
literally moved in to my college like
apartment for the summer like well all
my roommates went home and I like had my
own room I think I was just sitting
around myself and going to and from
[ __ ] work basically in a tie and it's
just doing busy [ __ ] work all day and
it didn't count for anything and so I
was kind of like I was like okay well I
can go out and get another [ __ ]
internship but at the time that's like
right when you allowed me to start like
kind of and teaching me like to start
helping you with your videos whether it
was like you know watching you edit and
kind of learning your style or holding
the camera or whatever like being your
basically your PA and I had been doing
that for a few months by the time this
had happened and you were like well like
you [ __ ] helped me all the time like
I have a business I can just give you
the internship credits for interning for
me and we like literally made it
official we filled out the forms and
everything and I got it certified and
you kind of saved my by little bit
because that [ __ ] sucks ya know on my
college credit I was an official intern
for J Marvin but I mean we laugh at it
because it is funny in hindsight yeah
but you did you or did you not learn
more working for me for as an internship
than I did for IBM's for you I mean you
you got obviously the bulk of your hours
for that internship on a Wednesday you
know there's a lot out we're stuck going
to that day but I learned how much time
could be wasted in a professional work
environment I'm in sports because like
if you're a like an intern or a lower
level employee there's so much time that
is just wasted that you can just be like
because like what part of our top is
like scrubbing through game footage to
find highlights which if you think about
it like how do you monitor how someone's
working if they're doing that all day I
come back to you with five highlights
who knows like where's the scale who
knows if I should have gotten 10 or 20
or 30 or one depending on the games I
watch what if they were just boring
games like there's no structure
in place to like make sure people are
doing quality work so a lot of times I
wouldn't be like [ __ ] killing it it'd
be like finding these great clips and
putting [ __ ] together and recording my
own videos and whatever and then other
times I'm like hello like is anyone care
that I'm doing this like I'm not getting
paid I know that yeah and the internship
credits gonna look like an internship
credit regardless if I get five
highlights out of this [ __ ] table or
twenty unless you don't fill out the
form Julian joke's on you but like
that's one thing I did learn from them
but back to your point like 100% like
this [ __ ] I learned when I first started
you know learning from you and you
started started letting me help you with
the videos and stuff is [ __ ] that has
helped me so much in my work now I'm
like you're the you like we're both
self-taught but like you self-taught
taught me your way of ending and that's
been crazy out for not just anything
like the whole nine the model of that
business was set to fail I mean it was
basically an ESPN for high school sports
like who wants to besides the parents I
will say that one thing about like
transitioning from eighteen nineteen
twenty twenty-one like college age to
mid 20s and then mid 20s so like 30s is
like I find that I just I care less
about a lot of stuff but like in a good
way
yeah you know like I think about the
things that used to make me so angry
when I was younger and like they just
don't bother me anymore
like it takes a you know really really
really valid reason for me to be like
outrageously upset about something yeah
it's it's a much nicer way to live your
life yeah you know it really is there's
some peace to that mm-hmm
like there's fucked-up [ __ ] that happens
all the time everywhere non-stop yeah I
can't stand a lot of people there's a
lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] out there that I
don't [ __ ] like but what I don't need
to do is waste my time and energy
thinking about it or talking about it or
anything you know mm-hmm that's true I
think one of the things that you gain
with age is just a level of perspective
with everything yeah I'm like it's
it's it doesn't make problems out in the
world less of problems
it doesn't make bad guys less bad but it
does make your daily life and your
outlook
like a little less [ __ ] hindered by
the [ __ ] that's everywhere like you're
able to kind of just like filter things
out and not really pay so much mm-hmm
emotion and attention to things that you
previously had done there's well I think
to like when we talk about as we get
older like what you want for your
birthday when you think about like a
like a two year old right think about a
two year old burger when they turn from
one to two that year was half of their
entire life like that it feels like a
long-ass [ __ ] time you mean like I'm
just struggling to like keep my head up
this is literally I offend a baby
forever first of all my whole life I've
been a baby but the first half of it was
brutal and I was upset the entire time
and then like a five-year-old one year
is one fifth of your life you know so it
feels like a really long time to you but
you know once you're 26 or 31 it's like
it's another piece of pie but the years
start to feel shorter and shorter
because it's one 30th of your life or
120 smaller portions and what you really
start to value is your time you know and
you're the the people that you're with
and stuff like that it's no longer about
this idea of what your birthday was it's
like when I turned 30 and 31 29 30 31
all of them you like what do you want I
want to do nothing
yeah I want I want me time before goal I
don't talk to anybody
snuggle in a blanket in my couch and
chill because that's what I value at
this point in my life is that those
times when I'm like I'm snuggled and
chilling I think the birthday is a great
example of like valuing time as you grow
up though because sure like directly
around the birthday like your birthday
week the Saturday you know what what do
you want to spend that time on as an
adult like what would you choose to do
with your time like it's a great small
but like I feel like broadening that
concept to like as a 25 and 26 and 27
come in your life like that's and that's
one thing that I feel like I've really
you know sort of had to deal with
learning in a good and bad and tough and
easy way as a 25 year old moving to 26
is like you are responsible 1,000% for
the time that you spend doing anything
and spending your time with certain
people or without certain people or
reaching out to certain people are not
reaching out or keeping yourself or
spending time on work or your body or
whatever it is that time becomes like so
much more intense and there's such a
there's such a magnifying glass over
that time when you get older because
it's like no one else is going to be
[ __ ] responsible for it except for
you and you start to learn the little
tiny ramifications that add up into the
big changes in your life based on how
you spend that time and there's a lot of
good that can come of that but there's
also a lot of like really sad times you
know like one thing for me is like you
know when you lose someone in your mind
you're like man I I wish I could've
spend more time with them and that sort
of thing comes from good things and it
also comes from bad things but it's also
like a moment of like realization that
you are responsible for your time mm-hmm
and that's the same for everyone on
earth it's just when you're younger you
don't necessarily have the tools to deal
with that by yourself you need help but
like yeah like that's one of the biggest
things I've learned as like a as like a
mid-20s person it's like my time is so
important and I am so you know
responsible I have such a responsibility
to to spend my time wisely if I want my
life to be the way I want it to be
mm-hmm so yeah I think the birthday
thing is like really indicative of like
where your mindset is right now my
mindset is right now well you just let
me know what you want to do on Tuesday
is your day but we already did go out to
dinner we got you your that's called
shogen in Los Angeles the car city it's
vegan and gluten-free sushi it's been
there
episode goes up my Instagram story will
still be live I'm serious so if you want
to see like I snap I snapped every
single dish we had
and I even tagged the place but yeah
it's this place this hole-in-the-wall
sushi restaurant or culver city that has
vegan and gluten-free everything on the
menu
yeah and it's sushi not open Mondays or
Tuesdays no Mondays or Tuesdays
just like the sand boarding place is
Bruno Idaho not open Mondays or Tuesdays
for no [ __ ] reason they're only open
for dinner it's relatively expensive but
it's your birthday and and like that you
they don't do takeout it's only dine and
only so like we can only go there and
have a dining experience we've gone
there twice both ah yeah nothing but
that's what keeps it special and nice
and fun and you really really enjoy that
food yeah yeah when she says does anyone
have any food allergies and we're all
like just just Julianne celiac and
they're like okay perfect amazing
perfect cuz everything there is vegan
and gluten-free but they even cater to
like people to have garlic amazing yeah
so well anyway thank you for having a
chat with me this was nice thank you for
spending six years of your life and
hopefully a lot more the best ones I've
ever had
same here ditto love you I love you too
birthday Julian thank you you're a
wonderful person we're lucky to know you
thank you for allowing me to grow it
grow into an adult and be a little bit
behind you but like catching up and
that's yeah I mean especially online
like with you guys listening like this
has been a great journey and I it's
crazy to look back and but where I was
when I started filming myself and now
we're on that now it's you know there's
only gonna get weirder and cooler and
likes
very Singh I promise II like frog one I
want a bike like what the [ __ ] was I
doing
like what was my life about that it's
completely crazy and different but thank
you guys you know for Oregon some
birthday wishes even though Yala early
is [ __ ] thank you guys for supporting
the podcast the support has been insane
you know lately and exceedingly insane
you know this podcast is felt more and
more special the longer we do it so
thank you guys for hanging out for 26
years of a podcast thank you this is the
longest-running podcast on iTunes you're
welcome we are we've been going for 26
straight years uploading every day it's
the world record well you just let me
know which funky birthday and then we'll
do that because you deserve it thank you
thanks for spending my birthday with me
because every wonderful week
[Music]
[Music]